wie lang ist ein erschien
sechs-meter-marke sechs meter wie lange
ist eine art schien was sagst du jetzt
ist der 44 dezember 2018 leute und wir
sind in österreich im weihnachtsurlaub
falls ihr euch gefragt hat warum schnee
ist was du bist du schön schwer weg mit
dem bergman
wir sind weihnachts urlaub mit der
ganzen familie und da habe ich mir
gedacht wird um eine gute angelegenheit
meine kleine schwester mal wieder ein
video zu holen und mich auch eine hilfe
sein bruder max klangcharakter auf
youtube abonnieren schwester geht mein
bruder antreten werden schauen wer von
den beiden am meisten ahnungen von chats
fragen hat also wir haben einen
21-jährigen studenten und eine gerade 14
jährige schülerin
sag mal das projekt lust die leute jetzt
ok meine kleine schwester hinter der
kamera magst du bist du bereit ich bin
bereit und natürlich auch tabea bist du
bereit
fangen wir direkt mal eine frage die
thematisch natürlich super wenn die
jetzige geografie ich hatte mal die
erste frage passt perfekt in die
aktuelle zeit ich wünsche euch wissen
wie viele weihnachtsbäume werden in
deutschland pro jahr verkauft war okay
ihr blick dahinter viel knapper wird
dann möchte ich gerne anfang habe ich
jetzt noch drei sagt ihr auch antworten
einfach gleichzeitig ok 12 318 millionen
dreijährige kinder kaufen gibt es ja
auch noch hapag- die tatsächliche anzahl
der weihnachtsbäume die pro jahr in
deutschland verkauft wird lautet 30
millionen wie viele menschen in
deutschland 85 millionen ca 430
millionen schon ordentlich wenn überlegt
ein haushalt braucht ja eigentlich nur
einen weihnachtsbaum und sagen wir mal
die meisten haushalte sind mit drei
personen
ok alles klar nächste frage wie viele
dellen hat ein golfball
123 65 65 50 die richtige antwort ist
336 alter schwede rutsche die sind 24
weniger als ist tage im jahr
nein es gibt noch nicht 360 tage leer
wie viele tonnen war die erde schwerer
nach dem bau der chinesischen mauer 12
jetzt würde vielleicht genauso einen
asteroiden dafür genutzt was schließlich
asteroiden wurden dafür die nächste
freie passt wieder auch perfekt an die
weihnachtszeit wie viele schoko
weihnachtsmänner werden in deutschland
produziert in einem jahr klein ist
deutschland so kleine schwester hat sich
im neuen auto von seinem papa auf einen
schoko weihnachtsmann gesetzt der dann
in dieses fein vorige leder richtig gut
eingezogen ist deshalb dürfte das ein
vorteil für dich sein an der stelle also
du musst mir nur vorstellen kann weiß
auch wie viele artikel die man essen
kennen würdest du dich pro jahr setzen
wenn es nur dich in deutschland gebe ok
eure antwort auf 3 12 13 millionen 500
mio die werden
haupt exporteur für
schoko-weihnachtsmänner ich würde jetzt
rückblickend auch 100 millionen wechseln
aber ich bin trotzdem her als wir ein
mehr als 500 millionen drin sind okay
die richtige antwort ist 145 millionen
schoko-weihnachtsmänner alter schwede
ganz kurzen zeit mit dazu
heute einige monate im jahr im 31 tage
einige 30 wie viele haben 28 12 3 1
[Gelächter]
sind wir mal ehrlich gemeint ist jung
meisten dann wieder aufhört
sie steht sie da fehlt an ihren fingern
irgendwas aber die kommissare 4
februar 14 uhr 24 34 jeder kirche auf
der hand ist ja ein motor mit 80 tagen
dann darf ich euch sicher positiv
überraschen mit der antwort also maxis
antwort war einst als antwort war vier
dieser punkt geht an tabea denn zwölf
monate im jahr haben 28 tage tritt alles
klar nächste frage wie viele aufrufe hat
das meist aufgerufene video auf dem hilf
mir youtube-kanal antwort auf 31 23 6
millionen 1,6 millionen
ok wenn beide 6 millionen gesagt
tatsächlich beide 6 millionen da gibt es
den punkt für beide den richtige antwort
ist 4,4 millionen die wundersame
zauberhafte folge mein freund mästet die
ärzte alles klar die nächste frage war
eine sehr feine damen und herren auch
kurz hinter der kamera bitte das
smartphone weglegen und lege sich das so
können wir auch lassen hinter werden
händen die so wie viel gramm hat ein
karat antwort auf 31 23
also ich sagen kann keine definierte
antwort geben bei karat ist doch
irgendwie auch reinheitsgrad oder also
da gibt es keine antwort habe ja sagt
sechsten keine antwort kannst du nichts
gewinnen es wäre ja ich hab ich gesagt
ja die richtige antwort ist 0,2 gramm
hat mich nicht warum
als nächstes will ich von euch wissen
wie lang ist ein erschienen
dietrich ich habe auch überhaupt keine
ahnung deshalb sage ich sechs meter mag
sagt sechs meter wie lange ist ein
erschien das sagst du
zwei kilometern der erschienen war ein
russisches längenmaß und er setzte mit
seinem aufkommen weitgehend die l 190
zentimeter oder so seien erschienen ist
genau 0,71 meter lang damit geht der
punkt
damit hat habe ich auch den gesamtsieg
bekommen ich bedanke mich dabei sein
durfte